Raymond Ibrahim
you've been the chronicler of this
for the last for for that goes back
1,400 years. Is anything I just said
about these phony countries, these phony
monarchies in the Middle East cuz I do I
give it to Netanyahu all day long and
people in the chat room and and guys in
my getter account and I got it. I
understand it.
I I I do appreciate that you're
defending Okay, I got that.
I got it and just to show you I'm not
picking on Israel and I'm not picking on
Netanyahu. I think the greater Israel
project is ridonkulous and it's got us
into a lot of stuff and Netanyahu is the
worst of the worst. They ain't any
better in Riyadh and they're not any
better in Abu Dhabi and they're not any
better in in Doha or Kuwait or any of
them.
Raymond, is anything I've been saying on
this topic
incorrect, sir?
No, I emphatically agree with what
you've said actually. Um
and as far as these Arab Gulf nations
I've uh
even before the alliances or you know,
the US alliance business partnership and
all that sort of thing. I usually see
things from a sort of theological
historical prism and I've always been
against the cozy relationship that the
United States has with these nations
based on who they are and what they
actually preach uh to their own people.
Uh uh as just one example, Saudi Arabia,
our great friend and ally and um uh
Qatar many many years ago and I was the
first one to call this out actually had
online uh in Arabic fatwas basically
upholding the doctrine of al-wala'
wal-bara' which I've spoken of before
which in short calls on Muslims to
always have nothing but hatred for
non-Muslims, okay? So, think about that.
Our friend and ally Qatar and Saudi
Arabia have fatwas telling their
citizens that while on the one hand
their kings dance and you know, wave
swords with our presidents and and
whoever, on the other hand they're
telling their citizens to just remember
when it's all said and done you have to
have hatred for these people in keeping
with Islamic principles.
And these are also the same nations that
fund millions uh spend millions to fund
and disseminate what we call radical
Islam and jihadism whether in the guise
of actual literature and uh school
curriculum and mosque literature in
Europe and around the West in general or
whether actually funding real live
Islamic jihadist terrorist organizations
uh as part of the zakats what you know.
So I've I've always known this this
isn't hidden. So it's always been just
somewhat surreal when Westerners say oh
these are our friends and allies. And
I've also been on record to say it's
really hypocritical for the United
States to say we're warring against Iran
because they are radical Muslims when in
fact the Shia variety of Islam is pretty
docile compared to the Sunni Salafi
variety which actually permeates and
promulgates and lives in those countries
you're talking about. Uh so the whole
thing is really messy. Uh it is it
should be a lot clearer if one
understood who who we're dealing with
but you know
diplomacy and realpolitik and uh people
exploiting the situation on both sides
is the way it is.
Raymond, hang on for a second. Uh also
Raymond quickly you're going to stick
with me but where people go to get your
books? I want people this guy has
written three of the best books I've
ever read on this topic. Where do they
go?
Steve, they can just go to my website
RaymondIbrahim.com
and all the books are there with links
to Amazon and elsewhere.
Senate, save yourself. Raymond Ibrahim.
What's the difference we've been told
the Crusades are terrible they're just
bad guys bad hombres they did terrible
things. I would say the historical
record is 180%
opposite that but of course modern woke
historians are going to tell you this.
But you say that hey there's a there's a
difference
in mindset between modern man and and
medieval man.
Particularly regards to the Holy Land in
the Middle East. What is that, sir?
Well, for the pre-modern medieval
Christians and stretching all the way
back, um well, the question of the Holy
Holy Land was very important and in
fact, that is the primary reason behind
the Crusades.
What Muslims were doing at that time
right before the first Crusade was
called in the year 1095 was basically
violence against Christians, destruction
of churches, which had been going on
incidentally from the very start of the
rise of Islam in the 7th century, some
four or five centuries before the first
Crusade when Muslims basically conquered
and annexed a massive chunk of what was
once the Christian world, you know,
almost three-quarters, we can say.
So, that but even before before the rise
of Islam, before Islam was created,
the Holy Land, especially following uh
Constantine Constantine the Great, who
created all these shrines and basilicas
and cathedrals and churches all around
the holy sites of Christ's life, for
example, the Holy Sepulchre, that was a
massive church structure, which was
built around all the regions where Jesus
where he was crucified, buried,
resurrected, and so forth. That church,
of course, was destroyed in the year
1009 by a Muslim caliph from Egypt and
that almost propelled a Crusade at the
time, but it didn't
and then and eventually a smaller
church of the Resurrection Holy
Sepulchre Church was built. Uh but
anyway, the same thing continued, the
Muslims again still attacking and
destroying and murdering
pilgrims that the Christians went to the
first Crusade. They couldn't just say no
and forget about the Holy Land.
Um sacred place was very important to
Christians and not unlike it is for Jews
and Muslims, actually.
Um and that itself is very interesting
because in as much as uh medieval
Christians fought tooth and nail, left
Europe simply to retake the Holy Land
from at the time Muslims. Cuz like I
said before, it was Muslim, it was
Christian. It was conquered, the Holy
Land around Jerusalem was conquered in
637 from the Roman Empire essentially,
the Eastern Roman Empire. So, it was it
was a just war, but at the same time
there was they could not leave what they
you know, the sacred lands of their king
Jesus Christ under pagan hands, under
pagan authority and defilement. And
today it's interesting because
you don't see that really. It's uh
uh Christians are either on one side or
the other of another religion. You have
Christians who are sympathetic towards
and
helpful of, let's say, Iran and Muslims.
Um, and you have others who you know,
yeah, they want the Holy Land, but for
Judaism. Okay, so that definitely is a
and that has to do with this, you know,
this idea of dispensationalism, which is
very, very modern and was created, as
I'm sure you know, just very recently
for political reasons. Um, but yeah,
very, very different.
>> be blunt. It's a it's a heresy. Let's
fall stop. Yeah, it's a heresy. But it's
a heresy. Um,
but
I got to bounce. I want to I want to
make sure people get, particularly for
young people. If you got young people
in your life, young men in your life,
two of your books are perfect. One you
give the heroes
of the Christian West in this fight in
in against Islam. And then you've got
these two militant those two swords of
Christ about the military orders are
amazing.
But my question to end this is that we
know that the radical theocracy in in
Persia is very dangerous, it's
incredibly dangerous, bad guys. But
they're not all that much better when
you scratch the surface, not that much
better with our allies in the Gulf, are
we, sir?
Oh, not at all. Um and I think I was
trying to allude to that earlier where
it it it's to me it's an artificial
distinction, one that's simply being
made for political points when anyone
gets up and tells us we have to attack
Iran because they are they represent
radical Islam. Because if that was true,
believe it or not, there's a lot more
radical uh organizations. Sunni Islam is
inherently more radical than Shia Islam.
Shia Islam is a minority uh form of
religion which has actually been the
victim of Sunnis historically. Okay? But
it's also uh I'm not trying to exonerate
Iran or Shiism. It's still a militant
ideology, you know, rife with martyrdom
against the other and so forth. But the
fact that we and then we go we cozy up
with these Arab Gulf nations, Saudi
Arabia, who are who who really are the
ones who fund and support and whose
ideology is all violent and hostile
towards the infidel and whose history,
if we look at the history of the
that I mentioned of Muslims, these were
all Sunni uh Muslim organizations. Uh
whether it's the you know, the Umayyad
Caliphate, the Abbasids, the Turks, the
the Seljuks and the Ottomans,
uh in Spain, same thing. These were all
Sunnis. So, um it is it's it's
artificial. It's an artificial
distinction when any talking head comes
and says, "Yeah, we're attacking Iran
because they're the bad radical Muslim."
When at the same time we're in bed with
the truly bad radical Muslims.
Yep.
Uh you're speaking at conferences this
week. I want the information where they
go to get your books, particularly the
one you've got out, the newest one.
Uh where do they go to get your writings
and all your content and where they go
to this uh this conference you're
speaking at this week, sir?
Thanks, Steve. Uh my books, you can get
them on Amazon easily or go to my
website raymondibrahim.com and you'll
see actual um links to all of them. You
can get signed copies uh for a small
donation that helps the website as well.
Check out my Substack and my YouTube. As
far as the the conference, it's very
interesting because it's actually
connected to my books.
It's
I'm glad you point out these books and
how they are actually inspiring,
especially to young men, but even women,
you'll be surprised. There's something
going on, Steve, where a lot of
Christians are dissatisfied with the
versions of Christianity that's been
told to them. This is the official brand
that you have to accept. And I think
when they read about these Christians,
they are just they feel liberated
because this is who they want to be.
This is This is their natural
birthright. This is their heritage and
this is what they want to resuscitate.
And I'm seeing this everywhere. Like I
said, even more so with women,
surprisingly. And these conferences, a
lot of them are very much
infused with the same spirit, hence why
they, you know, asked me to come along.
>> Yes, the church militant. The church
militant. They're tired of being wimps.
The church militant. It's going to take
that to sort this mess out. Raymond, I
appreciate you. I'm going to have you
back on later in the week to talk about
this conference this week and make you
aware of where it goes and hopefully we
can live stream it.
Thank you, sir.
>> Okay. Thanks, Steve. Bring back the
Bring back the
and the righteousness name.